- Well, as you guys know, it's the
25th anniversary of "Happy Gilmore."
- Good for Happy Gilmore.
Oh, my God.
- So what we thought we'd do, we put
together a little table read for you guys.
We have Shooter played by Phil
Mickelson. Happy Gilmore played by
Bryson DeChambeau. Tom Brady will be the
role of the narrator. And Aaron Rogers,
maybe his most important role to date,
he'll be Virginia.
Narrator, please.
Action.
- He's got similar hair
as Virginia right now.
Scene.
[Reel rolling]
- Golf clubhouse bar. Happy
Gilmore approaches the bar.
Shooter McGavin notices Happy.
Shooter turns toward the
bar and walks up to Happy.
- That was quite a show
you put on there today, Gilmore.
You were the talk of the tournament.
- Wow, thanks a lot.
- Well, you really crushed
that ball off the tee.
I'll tell you what. You know,
you'd be something in one of
those long drive contests.
Yeah.
You could probably make a very
good living, traveling around,
hustling at driving ranges.
- A bartender sets a martini
in front of Shooter.
- Thanks, Phil.
- That's, that's, you know, I know what you're
doing right now, and I don't like it.
So why don't you just shut your
trap before I put my foot in it.
- Happy grabs his beer and
turns back to Shooter.
Shooter walks around in front of Happy.
- Don't turn your back on me.
Let's get one thing straight:
This is Shooter's tour.
I've worked hard my whole life.
Paid my dues.
And now it's Shooter's turn.
And Shooter's not about to let
his reign at the top be spoiled
by some freak sideshow clown.
- Did you just call me a freak?
I was on this tour for one
reason: money. But now I got
a new reason: kicking your ass.
- Well, haha. I'd like to see you try.
- Happy grabs his beer bottle
and smashes it on the bar.
- Let's do it then.
- I meant on a golf course.
- Off-camera, a woman, yells and quickly
steps between Shooter and Happy
to break up the confrontation.
- Hey, hey, what's going on here, huh?
- Oh, I was just, um, looking for
the other half of this bottle
and, uh, there's some of it.
There's some, there's
some right there too.
- Why don't you just put it down?
- Yeah, I know.
- Shooter walks away from the bar.
- Just stay out of my way or you'll pay.
Listen to what I say.
- How about I just go eat some hay?
I can make things out of
clay and lay by the bay.
I just may. What do you say?
- Terrible.
[Laughing]
It's terrible.
- Aaron, you really brought it, man.
I'll tell you what, you saved
the whole scene right there.
- He did.
- It was good.
- Aaron was great.